joining us online is dr deborah so she's
a sex neuroscientist columnist and
political commentator
she's a brand new book out titled the
end of gender debunking the myths about
sex and identity in our society it says
very unstable things in our modern
moment dr so thanks so much for joining
us really appreciate it
hi ben thank you for having me so i only
start with what drove you to write this
book in the first place obviously one of
the most contentious
areas of american public life and
apparently international public life
is around the science surrounding gender
it has become basically unsayable to
even suggest that men
and women exist as biological entities
and are also different in a variety of
ways
of ways ranging from brain function
to to the biology of actual sex organs
so what drove you to write this the
biggest motivation for me
was all the questions that i've been
receiving over the years ever since i
first started writing about this issue
and that there is so much confusion and
what's really disturbing is that the
information that is being purported to
be
scientifically accurate the information
that's actually being supported by
some scientific organizations medical
organizations
even governmental policies are not
actually fact-based they're not actually
based in reality or as you mentioned
biology because for whatever reason
biology is seen as hateful nowadays
so i felt it was really important to
offer a resource for people
especially for parents because i would
have a lot of parents reaching out to me
saying
that this is in their kids education and
when i would try to find resources for
them i would see that a lot of what's
available
in the last i would say five even ten
years is
ideologically motivated and so i think
it's really dangerous especially to be
teaching this to be
to children who don't know any better so
let's talk about some of the most
controversial assertions
uh by some of the i would say
pseudobiologists who are out there how
about the assertion
that men and women are are essentially
social constructs even biology is a
social construct this is the most
extreme form of the argument
that there are men with uteruses and
women with vaginas
cnn the other day headlined that
individuals with a cervix should make
sure that they are
cervically screened for for cervical
cancer uh i
have no idea what an individual with a
cervix is other than a woman so
do biological men and women exist and
does the existence of intersex people
invalidate the notion that there are in
fact two separate
sexes so it started off with gender as a
social construct which is not true and
then it's expanded to gender as a
spectrum
and now it's expanded also to biological
sex being both
a spectrum and socially constructed
which is absolutely ridiculous
of course there are differences between
men and women and in terms of
people for whom biology determines their
gender 99 of us for 99 of us
our biological sex will predict how we
feel about our gender so this does not
invalidate intersex people this does not
invalidate transgender people
intersex people for the most part do
want to live within the gender
and biological sex binary most of them
do actually want to live
as one gender or one sex or the other
and for trans people obviously
it's just so happens that their gender
is the
opposite of their biological sex but
this is not to say that it's socially
any of this is socially constructed so
let's talk about the phrase that
gender is a social construct so that's
been a very vaguely defined phrase
generally speaking there's this attempt
to separate sex from gender biological
sex from gender gender being presumably
the the
set of attributes that we typically
assume to be more female or more male
that
essentially you're talking about
masculinity or femininity so
first of all let's define gender and
then let's discuss what in gender is in
fact a social construct and what is not
because the
idea that masculinity and femininity are
completely separable from biological sex
is not supported by the science
right so gender identity refers to how
we feel with relation to our bio
our biological sex so whether we feel
masculine or feminine and then the
gender expression is an extension of
that which is how we express our gender
identity so again most people are gender
typical
so if you're male you're going to be
masculine if you're female you're going
to be
feminine um the second part of your
question was referring to
which aspects are socially constructed
and which are biological
so again it all comes down to biology
and exposure to
testosterone in the womb so higher
levels of exposure
to testosterone are associated with more
male typical interests
and male gender expression so this is
regardless of whether
what someone's biological sex is so this
goes the same for
females who may be gender atypical who
are more masculine again are
more likely on average to be exposed to
higher levels of testosterone
in utero so when it comes to
transgenderism which apparently has
become
the real hot button here if you say that
men exist and women exist and a man
cannot become a woman
nor can a woman become a man
biologically this is unsayable if you
say this sort of thing
then you put yourself in danger of being
actually banned from from twitter
so can in fact a man become a woman or a
woman become a man
biologically speaking or are we just
talking about people who are suffering
when we talk about transgender people
people are suffering from gender
dysphoria which is a legitimate mental
condition
me personally i have no issue referring
to trans people using the pronouns they
want i will
if a trans woman would like me to
consider her to be female i will
but that is within the caveat of there
are differences between someone who is
born female
and someone who is a transgender woman
and similarly for trans men and men who
are
born male but the thing is as you say we
can't even talk about these differences
and i think that's really harmful to
society because one i for
for trans rights and i am in favor of
transgender rights i think for
for these communities if they want to be
taken seriously and to have their
concerns
heard they can't be promoting narratives
that are not based in fact in reality
because people are not going to take it
seriously
so in your book you go through a series
of myths among them the gender is a
social construct so when you talk about
gender identity or gender
expression so when why isn't gender a
social construct why isn't it completely
separate from biology
well i'm basically all the research
literature shows that is biological we
can look at
a couple of different areas one area in
particular
is girls with a genetic condition called
congenital adrenal hyperplasia
so they are exposed to higher than usual
levels of testosterone in the womb
and when they are born they gravitate
toward male typical toys
and male typical behavior even when
their parents give them more praise
for be for playing with female typical
toys so this speaks to the fact that
biology really is a very strong
influence and and the idea that gender
is socialized by parents
and caregivers and teachers and the
media and society or whatever else
is is just not true so let's talk about
some of the differences you know putting
aside the transgender issues just
between men and women more generally so
in your book you talk about actual
differences between men and women
uh what are the differences that that we
should of course we're speaking about on
average because there are people at the
tail ends
of sort of masculinity and femininity
who may have some similar attributes but
we're talking about the average man
versus the average woman what are the
differences that we should take note of
and that we should adjust for in sort of
our social science analysis
one area that i'm particularly concerned
about is with how this plays out in
dating and sex especially
for young people they're receiving a lot
of mixed messages from the media
in terms of how what to expect in their
romantic relationships how to go about
dating
and especially for young women i feel
like they're being told a lot of
nonsensical ideas like they should
behave like men in terms of their
interactions with men
that they should enjoy casual sex as
much as men and i think you know it's
whatever floats your boat i'm totally
cool with but if you are
if you feel the pressure to behave in a
way that is not comfortable for you or
that you don't actually enjoy
i feel like young people are just so
confused and there's so much
misinformation
and i know that you often will give
advice to your listeners so
um i i definitely think that fact-based
information is the way to go especially
dating is difficult enough as is so
let's talk for a second about some of
the
the myths that have been put out there
in the social sciences with regard to
basically by ignoring differences
between men and women you can come up
with these
bizarre statistics suggesting that women
are wildly discriminated against in
american society here i'm thinking
mostly about the wage gap and the
suggestion
that because men and women have pretty
significantly different preferences in
terms of the kind of jobs they like and
the number of hours they want to work
that this is just a reflection of
society's bias against
females do you talk in the book the end
of gender debunking the myths about sex
and identity in our society
about the differences between men and
women in terms of some of the choices
that they make about
family and about career and how this
actually impacts things like
average income i do to the extent of
of women on average preferring to have a
work-life balance and that the fact that
we're not actually having this
conversation in a very honest way and
that
we're blaming any sort of discrepancy or
difference we see in terms of the sex
ratio
on sexism i think is actually hurting
women because it's not helping them make
informed decisions that are actually
going to help them live
more meaningful and content lives so one
area that i do write and speak quite
often about is the
sex ratio and stem and the fact that it
is not a 50 50 ratio
however it is not due to sexism again
it's due to occupational differences
on averages which again go back to
on average exposure to prenatal
testosterone in terms of what we find
interesting
and i think it's really patronizing and
infantilizing to say that
women who choose to pursue different
priorities in their life
from men are somehow oppressed so dr so
you obviously are not somebody who would
consider herself i think on the
conservative side of the political aisle
i mean you used to write for playboy
you're not somebody who would fall
comfortably into like the center of the
republican party
and yet you've sort of been treated that
way by a huge swath of the media
certainly the the twitter audi
uh people for saying some of these basic
truths you've been treated as sort of a
social outcast in many ways can you talk
a little bit about the reaction
and why it is that the radical left
seems to have taken so much control
in in areas of science yeah i have to
say thank you so much ben for all of
your support over the years i mean you
would retweet some of my columns for
playboy so i really appreciate that
you know i i still call myself a liberal
and i think
it's really sad because these issues
that i'm writing about are not partisan
issues especially when we talk about
gender transition in children
which i don't think is appropriate
because the research does not back that
as the best way forward for these kids
this has become so polarized and i'm
thinking at the end of the day it
doesn't matter whether you're on the
left or the right
if these children are making decisions
that are not going to be beneficial to
them and their health
that's really what we should be talking
about so it's very strange for me
because i see many people who
would have been my ally so-called allies
maybe even five years ago
um they really do not care for what i
have to say and in fact consider me to
be a threat and so
i think that has woken me up quite a bit
in terms of seeing
what what the left has become but again
i still feel at the core i do have
liberal
principles so that's why i still hang on
to that label the book is the end of
gender debunking the myths about sex and
identity in our society it's a really
important read go check it out right now
dr so i really appreciate the time
thank you so much ben take care
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content